minha maior atribuição nesse mundo é ser
mãe eu vim aqui pra isso
mães de autistas como eu disse ele tem
grandes histórias comigo não poderia ser
diferente eu vou ter o maior prazer de
dividir algumas vezes minhas histórias
com vocês hoje a gente vai falar sobre a
trajetória do autismo na nossa família
eu tenho gabriel que tem 25 anos e ele
tem autismo clássico severo e eu tenho
mateus que tem 24 anos e neurótico o
gabriel começou a apresentar os sintomas
do autismo antes dos dois anos de idade
e nessa época eu comecei a procurar por
médicos que me dissessem o que o meu
filho tinha e eu chegava lá o médico irá
anunciar em tem nada ele só é imperativo
isso é coisa da sua cabeça teve uma
neurologista que virou pra mim fosse mãe
desencana ele só tem uma preguicinha
daqui a pouco ele vai falar vai ser como
as outras crianças tem criança que
demora falar teve e diagnósticos muito
errados
ele teve vários diagnósticos até chegar
o diagnóstico correto de autismo uma
dessas médicas também me disse que o
melhor que eu tinha pra fazer colocar
ele na escola que a socialização iria
ajudar é bastante então com dois anos
ele foi pra primeira escolinha
só que ele não melhorou em nada as
professoras não sabiam o que fazer com
ele
elas funcionavam mais como babás do que
como professoras que eu chegava na
escola é sempre uma correria atrás onde
ele estava aquela pessoa
as crianças até tentaram é incluir e
puxar para brincadeiras e tal mas o
isolamento dele acabou afastando essas
crianças
então ele chegava no começo na escola as
crianças vinham depois as crianças
passaram a nem vir mais porque não dava
nenhuma resposta e aos cinco anos ele
foi convidado a sair
e dessa escola porque a escola já não
tinha mais o que fazer com ele com cinco
anos
aí nós passamos para outra escola uma
escola regular também e aos 6 ele teve a
primeira confusão dentro da escola ele
além do autismo ele também tem epilepsia
e com a convulsão a escola entrou em
pânico e virou pra mim e falou que era
melhor eu procurar um outro lugar porque
eles não estavam preparados para ele e
não tinha outro lugar então gabriel
ficou em casa por quase três anos sem
escola e era uma coisa com a qual não me
conformava até porque eu sou professora
e eu acho que toda criança tem que estar
na escola mesmo então pra mim foi uma
época de muita dor e de muito sofrimento
mas aos 9 anos de idade é na minha
cidade tinha uma escola especial que
aceitava pessoas com autismo
apesar dele não ter o diagnóstico é
correto é foi esse local que eu procurei
e nessa escola tinha todos os tipos de
deficientes mas era a única coisa que me
restavam
aí eu falei eu vou encarar essa e levei
o gabriel mas no começo acredito que
toda mãe ela tem muita dúvida na hora
que o que procura uma escola especial
será que o meu filho não vai ser
estigmatizado por que tá nessa escola
será que ele vai ser agredido será que
ele vai agredir
será que ele vai se desenvolver nessa
escola então todas essas dúvidas
passaram pela minha cabeça neste momento
a escola especial é uma escola que ela
deve trabalhar com recursos com o
pessoal especializado e com técnicas de
acordo com as especificidades dessas
pessoas com deficiência
aí o gabriel entrou na escola e isso pra
mim trouxe um alívio profundo depois
dessas primeiras reflexões
isso pra mim trouxe um alívio muito
porque eu não era mais aquela mãe do
menino especial das outras escolas
as pessoas me apontavam mais eu era uma
mãe como outra qualquer dentro daquela
escola
e nessa escola o gabriel é começou a ter
algum progresso e também até por
iniciativa da escola eles levaram um
profissional muito especializado na
causa que conseguiu fazer o diagnóstico
dele aí ele teve diagnóstico de autista
clássico de grau severo
aos 12 anos de idade então foram dez
anos de perambulação pra saber uma coisa
que com quando ele tinha um ano e oito
meses eu já sabia
e nessa escola gabriel teve os seus
ganhos
mas eu achava que ele podia mais na
minha cidade tem duas escolas
especializadas para autistas é essa que
ele ficou até os 16 anos
aos 16 anos ele passou por uma outra que
que recebe os autistas dos 16 anos em
diante e ao passar para essa nova escola
eu já vinha com isso na cabeça de que
ele podia muito mais
então eu e uma amiga começamos a entrar
numa de conscientizará nossa secretaria
de educação
nós achamos que um bom programa para
essa escola seria o programa teach
gabriel começou nessa escola logo a
escola resolveu é ser nomeada só de
autistas e abraçou o programa teach eu
vi que tanto ele quanto os outros
meninos da escola tiveram um ganho assim
substancial do ano passado essa escola
recebeu um prêmio nacional de escola
referência no brasil em autismo
então o trabalho da mãe também valeu
muito aí
ali eu falo de contribuição em pesquisas
até porque há 20 anos atrás gente gente
não tinha pesquisa quase no brasil pra
falar de de autismo publicações
brasileiro
então muito menos ea gente nem tinha
computador em casa
como que eu ia fazer pesquisa meu
ex-marido pesquisava no trabalho trazia
tudo em inglês e espanhol
aí eu mesmo sem dominar as duas línguas
direito traduzir tudo pra entender um
pouco daquilo que eu achava que meu
filho tinha comecei a levar pra ir pra
escola e isso também ajudou bastante
gabriel teve um bom avanço só que ele
precisava de muito mais e eu achei que a
gente devia mexer um pouquinho na parte
de comunicação porque ele falou até os 4
anos aos 4 parou e não falou mais
e eu achava que com comunicação talvez
ele fosse adequar mais na sociedade é
ele fosse a baixar um pouco da ansiedade
e tal
então procurei uma fome na minha cidade
e eu e ela
começamos a nos capacitar para mexer com
a comunicação alternativa à comunicação
alternativa ela trabalha com recursos
gráficos e palavras escritas a fim de
dar funcionalidade para aqueles que têm
fala aumentar o repertório deles e
proverão um sistema para o indivíduo que
tem uma deficiência severa na área da
comunicação
no caso do meu como ele não tinha
comunicação nenhuma por pela fala né
eu até entende como as mães a maioria
delas olha e você entende um pouco que
seu filho quer mais e quando ele sai
quando está com outras pessoas e isso é
um pouco complicado para eles então pro
meu é eu achei que daria uma segurança
para a vida dele e fui me capacitar fiz
o curso pecs junto com a fono opex é uma
comunicação alternativa por troca de
figuras confeccionei uma pasta
para ele e começamos todo o processo da
comunicação alternativa
só que o meu filho tinha um agravante
tem até hoje que ele não tem muita
iniciativa
então eu fazia o processo junto com ele
mas na hora de ele pedir sozinho ele não
fazia preciso falar pra vocês é
trabalhoso é um pouco chato no começo
mas um belo dia eu estava no meu quintal
regando as minhas plantinhas e ele
estava dentro de casa
de repente ele apareceu entregou um
cartão na minha mão
era um cartão de biscoito
eu não sabia se ria ou chorava eu pulava
eu abraçava eu dava um biscoito
eu irei mas fui correndo para dentro de
casa peguei o biscoito de na mão dele
parabenizei muito e liguei pra fone
assim alucinada e falando a de hoje em
diante só vai ser mais fácil a gente já
conseguiu a primeira vitória e isso
gente ele tinha quase 20 anos
eu esperei 20 anos por esse pedido
demorou mas valeu a pena que vocês não
sabem a sensação eu falo até hoje
arrepiado
é eu comecei a pressionar a escola que
eu não queria fazer a comunicação
alternativa só dentro de casa porque
essa comunicação e tem que acontecer em
todos os espaços e quando a escola
começou a ver que estava dando certo
eles também se capacitaram e acredito
que hoje é uma das poucas escolas que
têm uma sala de comunicação alternativa
e tem uma professora só pra isso
então além de ajudar meu filho eu
consegui ajudar outros autistas que
estavam na escola uma bela noite eu
estava dormindo e olha que é difícil
dormir porque ele tem distúrbios do sono
e isso é um pouco complicado
eu estava dormindo e de repente acordei
sobressaltado com alguma coisa na minha
mão
ai quando eu olhei era ele que estava
colocando um cartão de nebulizador na
minha mão
ele tem bronquite ele estava em crise
acordou no meio da madrugada pra pedir
um socorro
gente vocês não imaginam para uma mãe
que o filho não te dá nada você tem que
adivinhar a hora que ele quer no
banheiro
você tem que adivinhar que dor que ele
está sentindo
você tem que adivinhar se ele tem fome
quando acontece uma coisa dessa e esse
tipo de comunicação
você ganhou assim a vida ali naquele
momento então esse momento pra mim foi
bem importante
e esse fazer cartão de comunicação
alternativa é uma coisa sem fim que é
cada um se faz presente outro você vai
aumentando repertório
então eu comecei a fazer muitos e
comecei a me interessar também por
estruturação de material pedagógico para
autistas porque eu vi que ele precisava
de mais
então comecei a a desenvolver alguns
materiais em casa pra ele
essa fonte que trabalha com ele viu
esses materiais e falou não eu quero pra
mim também pegou os materiais levou para
o consultório e começou a trabalhar com
os meninos de l dá certo
eu falei poxa isso é um canal para mim é
uma coisa que eu adoro fazer
aí eu pensei em falar eu vou voltar para
a faculdade vou fazer pedagogia e
começar a mexer com isso eo meu trabalho
de conclusão de curso eu escolhi sobre a
necessidade de estruturação de material
pedagógico adaptado para pessoas com
autismo
só que se você for procurar na
literatura você não encontra nada sobre
esse tema
aí eu falei onde eu vou achar pesquisa
pra isso e eu trabalhava numa associação
de pais
falei vou fazer uma oficina dentro da
associação e comecei a convencer outras
mães de que aquele era bacana aí eu
consegui convencer 12 mães
aí nós começamos as mães chegavam na
oficina e contavam para mim
poxa essa oficina não é pedagógico é
terapêutica
eu estava numa depressão eu só vi vídeos
médio e agora eu fico em casa com esses
materiais eu me distraio eu consigo
fazer alguma coisa do meu filho e eu
fico doida para chegar à quarta feira
para vir aqui nem remédio de pressão
tomando mais
isso foi uma resposta muito boa pra mim
e elas começaram a falar pras outras
pessoas quando eu vi a gente tinha mãe
tinha professor tinha terapeuta fazendo
essas oficinas dentro da entidade ea
última que a gente fez
a gente tinha 70 professores professores
até de outros estados que iam nos buscar
por causa da dessa necessidade e com
isso eu comecei a ser convidada para dar
esse curso em outros lugares em outros
estados
e eu pude perceber a dificuldade que o
professorado tem em relação a esses
materiais e as técnicas para trabalhar
com pessoas com autismo e isso dá pra
perceber se dest da educação inclusiva
muito de perto
eu percebi que eu cresci muito como
pessoa através dessa caminhada junto com
meu filho e percebi também que através
do meu trabalho de mãe e de professora
eu consegui nesta caminhada ajudar
outras mães como eu que no início
precisei tanto de apoio ea partir dali
eu já estava conseguindo ajudar mais
pessoas tanto a outros filhos como
outros alunos
educar um autista é muito complicado
um dos mitos que que persiste no autismo
é que eles são pessoas isoladas
eu acredito que eles são isolados por
falta de uma comunicação eficiente
eles são isolados também porque ele não
tem uma educação que seja de acordo com
as suas especificidades
isso faz com que eles sejam e sejam mais
retraídos e sejam mais isolados porque
não são compreendidos
o ato de como
cara você se fazer entender e ser
entendido com a comunicação a gente faz
cair um desses mitos do autismo educar
um autista demanda muito esforço físico
e mental
é um trabalho árduo e é um trabalho para
aquela pessoa que tem vontade quer fazer
acontecer e é pra uma pessoa que como
disse nilcéia ama porque você se você
não amava se não educam autista
só que isso dar te dar compensações
quando você consegue através da educação
ensinar aquela pessoa formá la para o
mercado de trabalho ou formá lá pra vida
você está contribuindo com a inclusão
social de uma pessoa para uma como eu é
uma das melhores coisas da vida
eu sempre falo que eu sou professora mas
o mestre ele eu aprendi demais continua
aprendendo apesar de ele ter 25 anos
cada dia tem uma novidade ea gente vai
construindo e desconstruindo conceitos
porque você percebe que é uma pessoa
multifacetada que está do seu lado e que
ela tem necessidades que são amplas
o autismo é parte de quem meu filho é e
também é parte de quem eu sou muito
obrigado